في الوقت الذي ساعات فيه اسرائيل في
السنوات الاخيره الى تهميش القضيه
الفلسطينيه واخراجها من دائره الاهتمام
العالمي والاعلامي وترويج نظريه النحل
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي سيحل ذلك
الفلسطيني الى العكس فان سيطره اجنده
وزراء حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيين قد تؤتي
نتائج عكسيه فاقتحام بن كبير الاقصى مثلا
قبل بتسونامي من ردود الفعل العربي
والدوليه واوصل ملف الانتهاكات في الاقصى
والقدس الى مجلس الامن من خلال طلب عربي
تمديد الدولي والعربي بزياره بنزين للحرم
القدسي واعتزام الائتلاف تعديل قانون
المستوطنات كل هذا وغيره يدل على ان
الموضوع الفلسطيني يفرض نفسه وبالقوه على
نتنيهم
يضرب مجددا حيث اعلن انه سيحرم قريبا
الاسرى الفلسطينيين من حقوق وامتيازات الى
جانب اطلاق اليد في البناء الاستيطاني ما
قد يقابل باضراب جماعي عن الطعام وانفجار
الميدانيه على الارض ويوحد الفلسطينيين
المنقسمين ضد اسرائيل وقد ينقلب السحر على
الساحر وتلف الحكومه اليمنيه الاسرائيليه
نفسها من خلال ممارساتها وتصعيدها على
الارض تجبر العالم والاقليم على الطاعه مع
المساله الفلسطينيه بواتيره متسارعه على
حساب الاولويه الاسرائيليه التي تقول انها
ايران
يعني هذه الحكومه على التطرفها وعلى سوءها
اعتقد انه يمكن فعلا ان تكون فرصه لدى
الشعب الفلسطيني هذه الحكومه منقسم حولها
الشارع الاسرائيلي لا يوجد اجماع حولها
منبوذه من حلفاء مهمين لاسرائيل خاصه في
الغرب الاداره الامريكيه واوروبا وايضا هي
يعني تغلق كل الافق امام الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي تدفع باتجاه توحيدهم التزاوج بين
يمين متشدد يغازل قاعدته الجماهيريه
ونتنياهو المضطر لتنفيذ جلدات مودريتش
لمساعدته تشريعان على الافلات من قبضه في
قضايا الفساد يفسر انها اول حكومه من اصل
ست حكومات لا يتحالى فيها نتنياهو مع
احزاب وسطيه او يساريه اكثر قبولا في
العالم زياد حلبي العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه